surprising sounds coming out of
Korogocho Celina Kumar and her fellow
musicians can transform any song into
orchestral music but ghetto classics is
more than just a unique Orchestra in one
of Nairobi's largest slums Godot
classics is my second family yeah we all
stay here like brothers and sisters yeah
so maybe if I'm bored at home and I want
to relax and have fun
I just come here growing up in Korogocho
is tough but says Saleem the worst part
is the stigma attached to it she and her
fellow musicians have discovered a way
to earn dignity and respect sometimes
how people talk you know maybe a folder
slams so you can't do anything so you
find it like it's eating me inside so
that's what the thing that I want to
change
Saleem is 18 and lives with her family
the orchestra is voluntary so she earns
money teaching music giving young people
perspectives is what organizers set out
to do even though people didn't
understand at first when we first
started everyone thought we were crazy
what's this classical music nonsense you
know as opposed to gang game you know
hip-hop or something cool groovy and so
the kids I remember our first concert
here we did some excerpts from Handel's
Messiah and we were like we could have
loved us
but the idea took off with funding from
the Kenyan Art of Music Foundation I
don't think that all the kids who are in
our program will necessarily be
first-class musicians or the best
musicians around but somebody like
Celine for instance she is extremely
talented and actually I feel it's a
shame that Celine didn't come into our
program when she was much younger
because perhaps if we had met her when
she was 8 or 9 who knows what could have
come out of this and there's still
plenty of young talent among Cora
gorgeous three hundred thousand
inhabitants Celine says ghetto classics
is a lot more than just a career
opportunity musicals enabled me like to
realize myself and know who I am and
what I want in future so at least it has
made me travel a lot and meet different
people so I think music has opened my
eyes to see and to know what I want
Celine has become a role model for
others here discipline and teamwork are
essential for any career and there is
hardly a better way to learn that in
Korogocho than through the ghetto
classics Orchestra